[Musique]
où nos collègues en fait il a fait son
travail l'a dit bas par rapport à ce qui
se passe au sein de l'école de façon
générale le climat est apaisé
par contre il a signalé des personnes
venant d'autres départements evreux le
voilà qui a pris llodra le poil est la
mosquée de pantin qui était pas dedans
et il envoyait aux services concernés en
disant bah voila moi j'ai fait mon
travail aux côtés sur conflent où tout
se passe bien il ya des intervenants
extérieurs qui sont venus et finalement
c'est des acteurs extérieurs qui vont
venir continuent d'attiser la haine
jusqu à l'attentât
si j'avais ya des choses à dire grosso
modo pour me renvoyer l'information
parce que je ne travaille pas sur ces
personnes je les connais pas la
problématique c'est le renseignement va
pas très vite et on arrive à des drames
vous faites de mauvaise communication
parce que ici effectivement les autres
services n'ont pas forcément été alertés
aussi ils ont été alertés le temps ça
nous retournons n'a pas été alerté nom
pareil honneur et ce dysfonctionnement
de communication entre services qui
arrive à ce drame et de rt 78 a bien
prévenu tout le monde et en retour on en
a eu zéro
[Musique]
niveau auquel j'ai accès et mes
collègues ce qu'ils ont pu faire monter
il n'y avait pas de suivi particulier de
cette personne en tout cas en direct
parce qu'après il ya toujours les
personnes qu'ils rencontrent donc les
personnes qui en sont rien qui font
qu'il ya des notes annexes en fête est
donc là par exemple c'est les personnes
qu'il a pu rencontrer qui ne sont pas du
département peut-être d'autres services
ont écrit nous ont pas dit bastien telle
personne est en contact régulier avec
d'autres avec la veille avec monsieur
sefrioui l'autre et là on aurait pu
travailler dessus en me disant voilà il
ya un réel problème travailler sur cette
personne qui sont rejetés par te manque
de renseignements territoriale s'occupe
de ce qu'on appelle du bas du spectre
donc c'est la menace et les menaces que
dangereuse et les prêts les prémices et
si jamais ça devient dangereux ou que la
menace se précise c'est la dgsi qui
prend la suite
[Musique]
c'est des contacts humains en fait
d'aller voir les personnes soit est rare
d'avoir des contacts avec les gens qui
nous font remonter les informations par
exemple atteinte à la laïcité c'est des
gens dans l'école qui nous dit bah tiens
il ya tel problème venait voir ce qui se
passe
[Musique]
notes sont lus après chacun son travail
j'allais dire lui c'est l'application
politique de l'enfer et les décisions
qui va prendre derrière et aux demandes
en on est plutôt content quand tous les
cas qui prennent en considération papier
dans ses décisions
[Musique]